Wow you're looking zazzy as hell today a
blat is a coffee stain on your brand-new
double-breasted three-piece suit it's my
first job delivering Blatz throwing
Blatz on people's doorsteps black black
off the cob when you're living off the
cob I think you're living high on the
hog you're living good I really wanted
to like her in the meeting but our
fashion was just off the cob we can't
have that representing our companies I
know this is a trick question because
you want me to fall into the trap of hot
potato but as you and I both know you
say potato I say potato but we're
talking about Tomatoes that man is
well-read he is a hot tomato I'm 1 for 3
somebody called a black write it up
which ass the nonsense that's the stuff
you don't want
that's the dregs he ain't you trying to
play with me in this quiz maybe it's a
derivative of pizzazz all my instincts
had been wrong
I don't know I like saying that a girl
is fine the apple pie
let your throat I knew Bill Clinton was
a clinch for the president when I saw
him play the gobble pipe on David
Letterman look it's a pickpocket a bobby
dangler there's somebody's bits and
pieces they talked about up a name
I'm Bobby dangler is definitely a man's
genitalia ninny fight exact like someone
who's not very courageous that girl's
got some Julius was that like
bootylicious before Beyonce coined it I
know it was gonna be that kind of party
I thought it was just gonna be like some
hors d'oeuvres and no air what's gonna
be up jelly ass and I'm a dance mom I
think in the grand scheme of things I
ultimately operated about 50% which I'm
not proud of in fairness it was not
multiple choice for me I had to just
roll with it but now I'm gonna get my
Bobby dangler out of here and I'm gonna
go jelly ass on a dance floor pace